- [Narrator] Seeking Secrets
is a social experiment
where strangers share
honest and complex truths.
We ask that you treat the
participants with respect.
Thank you for listening to their stories.
- [Woman] My grandpa died
two years ago and I laughed
because he abused me when I was a child.
- Um.
(intense music)
(phone ringing)
- [Woman] You died, later.
She died.
- I hope one day
I can see him again.
- [Woman] When it comes
to death, for me at least,
I've always been very fearful
of it ever since I was younger
and not so much of
death, but the afterlife
because there's so many
different religions and beliefs,
and it was very scary to me to
not know which was for sure.
When I was 16, my dad was murdered
and I just didn't feel, and to this day,
I hardly feel a spiritual
connection to him after he passed.
So that kinda freaks me out too
because maybe there is reincarnation
and that's why I don't feel
their spirit or their presence.
I don't feel that much pain
after a week of losing someone.
- Well, she talked about
kind of losing her dad,
which really I guess,
struck a chord with me
just because I lost my dad.
She said at 16 and I lost my dad at 15.
When she said that she
didn't feel a lot afterwards.
Typically when I think of
someone losing somebody,
I think of somebody going
through all the emotions.
- [Woman] When did you let yourself
start feeling those feelings of loss?
- Honestly? (laughs)
Sometimes I'm stuck at denial,
but it's only because I haven't
let myself think about it.
When my grandma passed, it was like,
okay, you have to focus
on getting into college.
Grandpa passed, it was still
like, okay, you're in college,
you have to keep going,
you can't fall behind.
And then with my mom the same thing.
And if I take that moment
to sit and really think
and let my emotions come out,
I'm scared that I'll be stuck there.
- [Woman] Hi, I just
wanted to talk really quick
about my grandma.
She just passed away and
it is a tremendous loss.
When all of us were
going through her items
and deciding who would get what,
and seeing family members
fight over different things.
It just felt really,
really gross and icky.
And we just felt like vultures, almost.
- That one actually hit really
close to home right now.
My grandmother's still alive.
She's at that age where
she's really old already.
We're actually thinking about
what would happen to her things.
And it sucks that a lot of it's
probably gonna get thrown away.
My grandfather passed
away pretty suddenly,
and him and I were like best friends.
When he passed away, my
grandma got rid of everything.
I couldn't get anything from him.
I have one article of clothing of his
and a little oxygen tool that
he used for his oxygen mask.
Like I have that, but that's, that's it.
Seeing family and friends
fight over material things
when someone had just passed
away, that shouldn't matter.
I wouldn't wanna give away her things.
'Cause I think about it too,
'cause she has so much stuff.
And I'm actually really
not ready to lose her.
I'm sorry, I love my grandma.
- [Woman] When I was 19,
my mom was a heavy drinker.
Ended up taking a lot of pills
that were legal, that were given to her
for her back pain and various reasons.
The sad part is she was a
functioning mom, and alcoholic,
and you know, drug addict.
Then one day she just
spiraled and moved out.
I was so mad at her that
I wanted her to die.
And I figured if she was
gone, life would be easier
and there would be less stress.
And two months later she died.
And the worst part about it
is I wanted her gone so badly,
and then when she was finally gone,
it wasn't what I wanted at all.
- Wow.
So my mom actually had
an alcohol problem too.
Just initially hearing that,
I was immediately like triggered by it.
I was like, "Oh," and then just
hearing what she had to say.
I related to a lot of it,
not necessarily with the hopes
that my mom would go away more,
so I would say the opposite.
I lost my grandparents and I feel like
that kinda made her spiral a little bit,
so she was drinking a lot.
That's what ultimately,
you know, killed her.
Yeah, hearing that definitely.
Yeah. Very similar stories I would say
- In 2020, my mother passed away
and ever since then it's only
really been my dad and I.
He has a lot of like anger
issues and he gets cranky a lot.
He gets mad if you don't
do one thing for him.
There are also other things he's done
before my mom passed away,
so there's just a lot of pent up anger
I also have towards him.
Wishing death upon a
person is very strong,
but there have been times where I have
probably felt that way towards my father.
- [Woman] My grandpa died two years ago
and I laughed because he
abused me when I was a child.
- I've always wondered
what it would be like when my dad passes.
I don't speak to him anymore
because he was very abusive.
Doesn't matter if they're
family, if they abuse you,
I mean, I don't know if I
would laugh when he passes.
It's sad when anyone dies,
but I don't even know if I'd be sad,
which is really sucks
because he is my dad.
I really miss the
relationship we used to have.
- I don't really know what to say.
I bet she just has this huge
weight lifted off her shoulders
that she doesn't have to
face this person anymore.
I'm guessing because that was
grandpa, she saw him a lot.
I'm angry that she was
abused and she was hurt.
And not saying they
deserve to die in any way.
I hope she can heal from that.
And if that brings her closure, then good.
- [Woman] This November, I
found out I was pregnant.
And at 12 weeks we found out
that we were having twins.
And at that same appointment we found out
that our little girl was dead.
Our boy twin survived, but I just know
that everyone wanted a girl
and I couldn't keep her alive.
I have been pregnant five
times with six children
and I have only brought
two into this world.
I miss her every day.
I miss all my babies every day.
- I have been pregnant three times
and I have one son
that's alive here today.
I got pregnant at 19
and with my then husband
and I was eight months pregnant,
and I went to the
hospital and they told me
that they didn't hear a heartbeat.
And so she was a stillborn,
so I still had to give birth
and go through the whole process.
And I very much relate to that.
You know, still feeling that pain
that was in 2018, and when 2022 now.
If there wasn't something wrong
with me that that happened,
that's my body that maybe
just the whole chain of events
wouldn't have happened.
- Society has put on so
much pressure for women
to make sure that a
pregnancy all goes full term.
I couldn't imagine all those losses
and all that guilt that weighs on her.
And so I would tell that mom,
please don't punish yourself
for something that is out of your control
because I know you would
keep that child healthy
as long as possible and
forever, if you could.
- [Woman] When I was, I wanna say nine,
my great uncle passed away.
Most people aren't super close
with their great uncles,
I guess, but I was.
The last time I saw him,
we had got in an argument
'cause I was really young at the time
and I was throwing stuff
and he got really mad at me.
I just said, "I hate you."
And I've always regretted it.
I hate myself for saying that.
I miss him dearly.
And yeah, I love you uncle Jack.
- When you're little,
you don't realize the
weight that your words hold.
She was like eight, nine years old.
She didn't like expect that to happen
after she said that she hated him.
I just really wish she didn't hate herself
'cause she didn't know.
- When my sister passed,
it was so unexpected.
She was perfectly healthy.
And I didn't think the day
that I last talked to her
would be the last day I talked to her.
Feeling like you didn't get closure
from the last interaction
you had with them.
I mean, it's, it's really devastating.
- My mom and I are more like best friends
than we are like mother and
daughter 'cause we're so close.
There have been times where
I'll like scream at her
and tell her I hate her,
and I don't want to talk to her anymore.
And I've only seen my mom cry
like three times in my life
and I saw her cry after
an argument we had.
It was one of the three times,
and that's when I knew that
shouldn't have said that.
Really hurt her feelings.
- [Woman] I am a very religious person
and I had a great grandfather
who I never truly knew if he
believed in the Lord or not.
And there was this one
time where I had a chance
to speak to him about it.
And I remember sitting there
and just having this pounding in my chest
saying, "Say something,
say something about it."
And I never did.
And then a week later he passed away.
And I fear that I could have been
his only door into salvation
if he hadn't found it already,
and I let it pass me up.
- I can relate to that.
I also grew up Christian.
I know that feeling of
wanting and craving everyone
that's close to you to
have that connection
and that relationship
with God that you do.
I think in a way that there is
this sense of guilt within the church.
You're taught that if
you don't believe in it,
you're condemned to hell.
Kinda similar to what
she said of feeling like,
"Oh I could have been
that salvation for him,"
but that's not up to us
at the end of the day.
That's a choice that her grandfather made.
You know, that's something
that if he was at peace with,
that's not something
she should have changed.
I think that she should
be at peace knowing that
wherever her grandfather did
go is where he intended to be.
(calm music)